bismillah alhamdulillah peace be with
you
thank you for tuning in to the D Shama
your host and this week you know that we
know that there are more women coming to
this way of life this way of life that
provides peace happiness contentment
satisfaction and then when you die you
have your place in Jenna paradise
because you're living according to the
way that your crater wants you to live
and there's always a void in the heart
when people they have money they have an
entourage of friends and they're in the
nightclubs and you know they're models
and they're celebrities but there's
always that void you're never content
you're never satisfied until you find
the truth until you find the purpose of
life and Alisa Kim who's our next guest
she was a model she was in that high
society lifestyle but she wasn't happy
and she didn't just satisfy for a little
she wanted more she wanted a lot more
she wanted that peace that money can't
buy she's found in Islam and more women
like I said are coming to Islam so we're
going to hear from a woman why she's
decided to accept Islam why she
observing hijab and her story is
something so motivating you don't want
to miss it we'll be right back with
Alisa Kim here on Adi show
this is the this is the thing you know
this is the days of 13 June you know
this is the Salam alaykoum he's been
with you like no salami rahmatullah how
are you al hamdulillah
I'm very well brother how are you good
thank God hamdulillah I like to thank
you personally and I'm sure our audience
is very excited to have you here on the
D show as well I know where he's my
pleasure my honor as well tell us how's
the Deen show reached your town
definitely I mean there are many fans of
the Deen show here so my close friends
are very excited that I'm going to be
speaking well that I am speaking to you
right now so mashallah tell us a little
bit about your life before it's not well
life before Islam I was a Christian
raised in a religious Christian family
um was you know good so-called good
Christian girl I went to church I you
know I created all this kind of thing
but it was still very much the you know
Christian still can do many things that
Muslims cannot do of course you know I
could still get away with a lot of
things or forgetting to pray kind of
thing but um my occupation also before
this was not exactly Islamic Lee
inclined I was a model and also an
actress um in Thailand I was modeling in
America for a while as well coming from
that kind of background into Islam is
also kind of a journey especially with
the whole putting on the hijab and
everything but um yeah before before
Islam I wouldn't say that I was you know
a party goer and you know doing all
these kinds of
so-called socially unacceptable things
yeah but I was always kind of a person
he was reserved and who likes religion
but they didn't really know what
religion I should you know which way I
should go because I I believed in God
definitely believed in God but I was
searching for something that had more
purity because um you know being someone
who likes religion and always grounded
myself in religion I came to a point
where I wanted to know what is the truth
which one is the true church the one
true church that I can count on and I
can you know I can feel purity from
because there's 200 or more than 200
nominations in the Christian Church now
so it kind of started from there you
know what is what is the true church
what is the true calling what is the
pure way that I should be worshipping
God and so on and so forth
so yeah so that's that's how I actually
came to start thinking about Islam -
tell us real important question at what
point in your life did you really start
contemplating about the purpose of life
well I guess for for many it's along the
same lines as many people you know you
faced a life struggle or crises in life
and that's exactly what happened to me
everyone has a different struggle in
life and for me it was two years ago
when I had many things coming in at me
at the same time and I felt like my life
was just spinning out of hand and you
know I had just you know jumped out of
one problem into another problem and
wanting a new a new kind of lifestyle
and testing new lifestyles and finally
that it was just not right for me and
feeling very out of control so at that
point I really felt like I wasn't myself
and I wanted to be myself and I didn't
know who I was so it was at that point
really that I started to search again
but again I was a Christian before so at
that time I wanted to ground myself in
religion as a Christian so um but again
like I said before I didn't find what
wanted I didn't find something that I
found to be the most pure so it was at
that time what I needed that grounding I
wanted a grounding that I didn't find it
that I started search for something else
tell us also your experience as far as
going back into the roots of
Christianity you really want to dig deep
because you really really were sincerely
earnestly wanting to know if this was
the true for that yes yes well um yeah
well you know I'm a very I would say
that I'm a very academic person you know
I when I was in school that I just
thought if I could be a professional
student that would be great
so I kind of took this on you know
looking for what I'm supposed to be
doing you know what religion am I
supposed to be how am I supposed to be
practicing my religion I took it on as
academic exercise so I went to the
bookstore and I bought a whole stack of
books you know one thing to really know
the truth wanting to lead but I took it
from a non religious point of view first
I got historical books books on the
Bible books on Christian history but
from a very historic point of view so I
I read the history and I mean some of
the stories I knew already some some of
the stories made me feel uncomfortable
because of course there were the
Crusades and there's so much bloodshed
that I just felt so uncomfortable why if
this religion is supposed to be correct
why do you have to kill so many people
why do you have to force so many people
into it so I didn't quite like back to
much so I left the Christian history
aside for a while because it made me
feel very uncomfortable then I went into
a study of the different languages and
in that maybe if I could read the
difference um scrolls or the different
ancient manuscripts then I could be on
the right path then at that point I was
you know me me being me and me being
very the perfectionist type I need to
know the anti-media acts build on Arabic
go learn Aramaic look
learn all the ancient language so I can
read the manuscripts and compare them
for myself without being lost in
translation but Sao Paulo at that time I
was also given a booklet but came just
in time because it did all of that for
me so I got to read you know the
comparisons of many words that could
have been lost in translation for
example the phrase son of God having to
do with prophet ISA or Jesus but the
word son in Arabic or Aramaic which is
these two languages are very close
together that word son can actually be
translated either as son or slave now so
it could either be some about a slave of
God so when when I got more clarity and
a linguistics that helped me a bit on my
search as well so then I moved away from
the history ends away from linguistics
and then I was looking more at the
theories when I got to a point where I
thought wow there are some theories in
Christian theology that but wasn't
really telling me that I don't really
understand obsequious I would have liked
and maybe I didn't really believe in
them like I should or maybe I shouldn't
so I was thinking about that as well for
example Trinity Trinity never really
gelled in me even though I came from a
religious Christian family it was just a
concept that I mean to me now I feel
like it's because Allah was really
protecting me that all these things then
actually implant into my brain yeah I
always believed in God but I always felt
that the Son of God or Jesus was apart
from him you know they were connected in
some way but God is God son his son
you know like father is father son a son
it's separate so that didn't really gel
for me I didn't I don't really got that
and then there are other aspects of even
crucifixion but I couldn't quite accept
I couldn't accept for example um if
there is some rapist out there who
believed in even believes in Jesus does
he really go to heaven with the rest of
the Christians who are striving so hard
to keep themselves good I mean is there
no justice system in that or you just
have to believe in Jesus and that's it I
couldn't quite accept that as well so so
that led me to
research that I was doing very much an
epidemic from academic research from
topic to topic you know so I went I went
quite deep because I really needed to
know for myself
I'm one of those people who won't I
won't jump into something without
knowing as much as I can making not only
educated but very much a moral choice as
well no I don't know I never want to
choose anything without fully
understanding and knowing and actually
feeling it in my heart as well where it
can't have defects in it can it if it is
literally God's Word yes it cannot have
defects I mean this was written by men
you know that this is a collection right
even if you have Matthew Mark Luke and
John the Gospel according to according
to right the thing about the Quran and
the biggest and you know I'll leave you
with this is the biggest thing for me is
if the Quran is exactly what it says it
is and this doesn't matter whether
you're Muslim or not if the Quran is
what it says it is the Quran is
literally the Word of God
delivered via Gabriel to Muhammad who
was an unlettered man who couldn't read
or write write he was just told to
recite right that was the first thing
right first thing they stole recited
right so if it is literally the Word of
God then that's pretty important to me
and before I became Muslim I said if
this is the Word of God then I'm going
to follow it because I'd be stupid not
to
I am Not Afraid to stand alone
I am Not Afraid to stand alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand alone I am not afraid to stand
alone
if allies by my side I am not afraid to
stand
tell us along your way did you look at
any other religions well along the way
I've been exposed to many religions um
you know my family in Thailand um a lot
of them are Buddhists that's what most
Thais are so I've been exposed all my
life to Buddhism actually um I know if
you can do this as well of course there
were many Jewish folks that grew up with
me in Boston so I knew some of these
other religions and I knew the Jewish
religion and the Christian religion the
Islamic religions they were connected in
some way but it wasn't until two years
two years ago or maybe one and a half
years ago when I started reading that I
actually knew that they had the same
background I didn't actually know that
Islam came from the same Abrahamic roots
as Christianity and Judaism so um yeah
it was kind of an eye-opener but I did
look at a few other things that I never
I mean I never really got deep into them
because I believe in God I I sincerely
and very much deeply believed in God so
I wouldn't ever look into anything more
more than Judaism Christianity and Islam
please I know this is a sensitive topic
for a lot of people and we never want to
disparage on anybody never want to
intentionally put any other religion
down that's not our agenda or go but
many people attribute violence to Islam
and you had mentioned in your search
that you found a history of violence and
Christianity so some people might say
hey you got it mixed up it's actually a
slum is the violent religion and
Christianity is all about love so what
would you can you expound on this a
little bit more um yeah sure well I can
only help understand it from my point of
view but I'm taking it away from
historical because I think not many
people can relate to that already the
whole bloodshed in terms of the sharing
has you know has passed it's it's
centuries ago but I think a lot of
people see Islam as violent now is
because of the
recent past so you know 9/11 everything
that came after that so that's why
people are thinking wow Islam is so
violent all these things that you have
to remember it every religion not just
Islam but also Christianity and all
other religions there are you know
practitioners of every week of every end
of the spectrum and ever everything any
team so they are going to be good
Muslims and non-muslims that's just the
truth there are good good Christians and
bad Christians there there are good
people and bad people in every religion
so you know facing a whole religion on
what a group of people do on a small
group even a group of people do is I
mean that I don't see that as fair you
know I was very blessed to grow up in a
family with a father who always taught
me not to hate and always to look at
other angles and you know have a open
mind a bigger vision than than what I
see on television or what I hear from
other people and that's what I kept in
in my mind so I thought you know this is
just bad people I mean I can't just face
a whole group and a whole religion just
on this small group of people and as you
know I did more research Islam is such a
peaceful religion Islam preaches nothing
more than peace because it's not means
peace no it comes from the root of or
one of the roots is Salaam it means
peace you know when we say Islam alikoum
and in these movies there which someone
says assalamualaikum it's the bad guy
but actually they're saying peace be
unto you so it's kind of an oxymoron to
me when I see that now get it get me
back to the whole violence bit again if
you just it very simply if you just go
to youtube and you Google a few key
people you will see that Islam even to
captives of the Taliban I mean there is
a lady journalist I don't remember her
name at the moment but she was if you're
the captive of the Taliban and this was
supposedly the most cruel regime in the
world at that time but clearly she was
you know her story is that you know it
treated her so well they treated her so
well and
one of the things that you know she
promised them if she got out and she did
without being touched at all even in new
clothes and all these things is that she
will be Quran and she did and she
remembers you know people who had held
her captive and and how respectful they
are and she read the Quran and she is
now a Muslim now if if the most hated
and scary regime in the world is violent
and oppressive and torturing people
why would someone we know who was a
captive say all these things and then we
look at all of the you know American
military and UK military who were in
Afghanistan all these places and in the
Middle East who are reverting or
converting to Islam why would they do
that if they didn't see something that
all of us or everyone else who just only
sees media didn't see you know so
they're there these evidence is that you
know if you just open your mind open
your heart a little bit more just to see
now it is it true is are all these
stories really true that it's really
violent and you know all this media
that's feeling it and is it really that
violent challenge yourself to go and
really search and get the truth
no because not everything that is being
fed you you know on the media is the
truth so these people did take up the
town for soldiers were put into a
specifics situation where they had to
mix with the Muslims there and you know
of course know there are other people
that I even know of that we're
challenged by their Christian friends to
go and find out why Christianity is
better than Islam and then they find out
that Islam is better and have become
Muslims so you know and all these things
to me is just you know it's just part of
media and if someone is open enough to
go and see for themselves they will see
that Islam is just so peaceful there's
just so so many stories out there you
just can't deny it
mashallah hum did it last so now you've
accepted Islam submission to the crater
not the creation you're Muslim you one
who's doing the will of the creator and
obviously there are some guidelines
there's some there's a lot more
structure in Islam
you have to pray five times a day
minimum you can pray more obviously
there's a you're constantly developing
yourself with all these things that the
Creator wants us to do then our blessing
for us and you can't just do your own
thing you got that modest way of dressed
you have the the character development
constantly it's from A to Z from you
when you go to sleep to when you wake up
everything is laid out in Islam some
people look at this as you know a burden
how was it to you we know it's a
blessing it's not a burden but how was
it for you in the beginning all of the
structure and the guidelines talked to
her about this um actually for for me
like you'd like to mention that I like I
like structure
I like guidance I never thought that you
know being able to do everything that I
wanted to do was correct because what if
I'm doing the wrong thing so I actually
like these sidelines and for for me for
example the five prayers at first I mean
it's a challenge for um anyone starting
to knock this Islam for the first time I
mean the the Arabic is a challenge that
remembering to pray is a challenge that
had me in the concentration is the
challenges you know but but for me I
liked it because I was praying a lot
already as a Christian it's just that it
wasn't structured and and so having the
prayer being mandatory and having this
relationship with Allah being um alive
all the time and constant in my life
gives me extreme comfort I love going
into my cell at times you know because
that's my time to talk to a law tell him
what's going on you know asking for help
or maybe you know give him praise for
whatever good thing that just happened I
mean I really enjoy my place a lot of
times even though at first of course you
know Arabic was really hard for me I'm
going to recite things in Arabic but you
know over time and with some guidance
from good brothers and sisters and also
the teachers you know it comes a little
bit faster once you really set your mind
to it and as far as you know other
changes for example dressing actually I
like being more covered actually now I
feel more like
myself you know I'm coming from a tight
background my ethnicity
my mother let never really let me out of
the house without long sleeves and long
pants anyways so it's not as though I
was totally out anyway but now it's just
it just feels more comfortable I don't
have to be self-conscious about my body
figure you know I don't have to worry
about you know what's my what is my hair
going to look like you know what is that
person going to think of me not being in
style whatever whatever it is that you
know the world puts on you but now it's
more okay I'm going to leave the house I
beliefs it I think I look I look fine
but does Allah do do I think that Allah
you know likes what I'm wearing no it's
a very different kind of thought and and
and and all this kind of ties into you
know knowing that you have a purpose in
life you know you're here to place a law
so that when you go off to the Hereafter
you've got it made there I mean you have
everything there this is just a test and
if you do well you're you're going to do
well on the last day that that's all
that you have to think about now before
it was just like every which way I don't
know direction on it now I have
direction now I have some guidelines of
what I'm supposed to do and you know and
and it makes sense to me that when I
feel guilty or if I feel something amiss
that's my reminder from Allah that he
and you want watch it watch it there's
something a little bit wrong gonna
change a little bit I mean I like that
happy that you know a little reminder so
I feel very good when I'm able to follow
and I'm able to you know feel like I'm
pleasing Allah it's a very sweet feeling
it's really sweet feeling before for me
all all destruction has been comforting
no I don't think there's a better word
than that very comforting I don't have
to guess and I don't have to wonder am i
doing the right thing am I going the
right way because if I'm following the
guidelines which is actually there
they're not actually not that difficult
then I feel comforted that I'm doing the
right thing and going the right way
take that simple step that you asked
your maker to guide you that he'll guide
you yes
I advised this a lot for people
researching put your head on the floor
and in the in the state of prostration
like all the prophets did and ask the
creator of the universe to show you the
way to guide you to the straight path
and someone who sincerely ask for
guidance Apollo they'll find it in your
son that's it okay we only got a few
minutes left so in last question tell us
what would you say we as men we're
always saying look talk to the Muslim
women talk to the Muslim women because
people have this false persona that
Islam oppresses the women bla bla bla
bla bla bla
all this just garbage so now we have a
Muslim woman one who's fighting to wear
hijab she gets up every day you know
with all of the baloney phony false
phony media she's still wearing the
hijab
so now that you have their ear you know
for the people who are like okay it's
long oppressors women take off the hijab
sister come on you could do it but you
actually want to do it you know what
would you say to them well I think they
have to put themselves in the shoes of
the person who's founded God first not
looking from that side because for a
person who's wearing the hijab they've
chosen to do that they haven't been
forced to do anything wearing the hijab
actually is taking you out out of
oppression to me because I was a model
you know I based my self-worth on what
people thought of me and how I looked
and how my body looked you know that's
where I got my self-worth if you know if
I posted a picture and Facebook and I
got however many likes that makes me
feel good in that bow
they tell how good I am now but actually
now being dressed in fully a job and
wearing my head start
takes me completely out of that because
people no longer objectify me they no
longer see me just because of my figure
or my beauty they don't you know judge
my style
all they see now is my personality and
my brains
what more liberation can you have than
that you know when you say that Muslim
women are oppressed you have to think of
it in a different way you have to look
at it from the Muslim woman's point of
view not from the outsider's point of
view yes it might seem like while
they're really you know covering their
women and you know keeping them at home
how horrible is that but these women are
not being forced this is something they
willingly do it's wearing the hijab for
Muslim woman is active worship and it's
a active protection it's a protection
from her being objectified and made as a
sexual object and like I said now that I
know that I'm dressed this way I feel a
load that has been taking off of my
shoulders I don't have to worry about
being sexy I don't have to worry about
wearing the latest style I don't have to
worry about how many people are looking
at me when I'm walking down the street
now what I worry about is if I'm
representing myself well if my character
is being shown how am i conveying my
thoughts I want people to see me now and
people do see me now give me more
restart give me more dignity I have more
dignity now because people see my
character and see my education and see
my intellect listen to me and not just
look at me so for the people who are
saying that hijab is oppressive no it's
not it's the most liberating thing that
a woman can do covering up this beauty
is not something that is oppressing it's
actually liberating that's all inside
it's it's it's the best thing that I've
done in a long time
aside from shadow of course mashallah
hamdulillah that's why we say go to the
Muslim woman talk to the Muslim woman
because I don't think any man could have
said it better than that so you've heard
it from the Muslim woman and we thank
you so much for all those people who are
searching who are deep down inside
they're trying to fill that void with
drugs money rock-and-roll sex all the
other things and they need to hear your
story you went through all of that
inspiring actress model and you came to
the truth you really took a scientific
academic approach and you concluded that
Islam delivers the truth it's from the
crater not the creation it's not
organized by man or men organized by the
creator of mankind who sent Islam as a
mercy to mankind submission to the will
of the creator not the creation thank
you so much hopefully people will get to
benefit from your story people who are
searching for the purpose of life they
want to live the purpose of life they
found it here at the detail thank you so
much sister thank you okay thank you for
having me on the show made a crater of
the heavens and earth make you steadfast
and make your story story that benefits
so many people all over the globe thank
you so much assalam alaikum peace be
with you I can see I'm going to do so
that was Lisa Kim aspiring actress model
found peace and purpose in Islam and you
could find the same thing that she found
you just got to clear your mind of all
the junk that you've been told media all
these false stereotypes and just ask the
Creator to guide you because I mean look
who's going to give you the guidance
other than the one who created you so if
you ask you so shall we see but if you
just keep worrying about you know what
you're going to wear for them to the
nightclub you know you want to be like
Tom Cruise you want to be like 50 Cent's
you want to be like you know all these
other people who are just really they're
taking you away from the purpose of life
taking you down the wrong way towards
misery misery loves company so you're in
the company of those who are miserable
from the outside everybody looks good
for the picture it's all smiles or for
the 3-4 minute music video but inside
you don't get to see all of the
that people are feeling so you tuned
into the Dean show and you want to go
from pain to pleasure to feeling good
really having contentment solace and
that's what our sister found and over
1.8 billion people all over the globe as
we find in Islam and Salaam provides the
proof in the evidence that you can know
for sure that it's the truth it's not
blind flate faith no Aslam you can touch
it you can feel it we have the Quran
verbatim Word of God you can look into
it scientific miracles how you were born
the description of the embryo everything
science is there these are signs for the
person who wants to know
so as the last final messenger said to
mankind of problem and peace be upon him
he said that for the one who calls
someone to good will have the reward
equivalent to the one who does the good
Sahih Muslim this is an authentic hadith
so you know if you like this story now
you can share this story you can go to
our Facebook you can go there
like our page make sure you like our
page so more people can can I have
access to this information help us and
if one person benefits from it and you
helped you'll get the reward did you
just not hear the hadith you can go and
also join our Twitter page the links are
here and pass along the Deen shall pass
it to your friends your family to your
co-workers we've gotten these people
from all over the globe some of the
scholars people who have helped you
attain so much knowledge by watching and
people who accepted Islam from all over
the globe so we've done the work now you
can help share you know that's the least
we can do because caring is sharing so
go ahead and share the Deen show like us
on the Facebook and follow us on the
Twitter the Deen show calm and you can
tune in here every week for a new show
God willing we'll be here to help you
develop a better understanding what the
purpose of life we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you